[Musica]
tir è finito è finito due video prima
purtroppo perché sarebbero state due
collaborazioni ma a causa covip
il fatto che io mica gi addosso ad
uscire di casa
ho dovuto scartarle è questa serie di
video buttati
voi l'avete inondata d'amore io non ci
avrei mai sperato con i pochi mezzi a
mia disposizione sempre per causa covip
questa serie di video che io ho scartato
perché non ho mai trovato il modo di
farla sono riuscito a farla e mai avrei
immaginato che sarebbe andata così tanto
bene che il responso sarebbe stato così
alto sia a livello di commenti sia a
livello di visualizzazioni ed è la prima
serie che mi mancherà davvero il
problema di fare una serie che va bene
con la gente e che non va bene nel mio
cervello perché purtroppo c'è sempre la
sindrome dell'impostore in agguato
[Musica]
cosa ci riserva il futuro di questo
canale
ne ho la più pallida idea perché ormai
lo sappiamo è lei il punto più alto del
canale l'abbiamo superato tanti anni fa
e quindi è un po offuscato quello che
saranno i nuovi video i nuovi format
ma a me piace da morire questa cosa qua
proprio per quello perché vuol dire che
ci posso buttare qualsiasi idea folle mi
venga in mente e lo so che voi vi
lamentate sempre del ma quanti gli
sfondi cambi beh cioè il ma a me piace
cambiare sfondo perché da un'identità ad
ogni singola serie di video che faccio
tutto qui grazie per aver guardato
questa serie grazie per aver ridato
linfa vitale al canale e noi ci vediamo
con i prossimi video che non so quando
saranno non so quanti non so dove
ma ormai siete abituati a me che faccio
un video
ogni due mesi vi eravate abituati bene è
invece bastardi ciao
[Musica]